we're now in the home stretch we just
need to evaluate this third surface
integral which is over this top part of
our little chopped cylinder right over
here so let's try to think of a
parameterization and let me just copy
and paste this whole entire this entire
drawing just so that i can use it down
below as we parameterize it so let me
copy it
copy and then go all the way down here
and let me paste it
let me
paste it okay that is our shape again
our surface
and then let me go to the layer that i
wanted to get on
and then let me start let's start
evaluating it so what we want to care
about is the integral over surface 3 of
z
d
s and surface 3 here we see that the x
and y values essentially take on all the
possible x and y values inside of the
unit circle including the boundary and
then the z values are going to be a
function of the x values we know that
this plane that this
this top surface right over here s3 it
is a subset of the plane
z
z is equal to one
minus x it's a subset that's kind of
above the unit circle in the x y plane
or kind of the subset that intersects
with our cylinder and kind of chops it
so let's think about x and y's first so
first so x so let's think about in terms
of polar coordinates because that's
probably the easiest way to think about
i'm going to redraw kind of a top view
so i'm going to redraw top view so that
is my y-axis
and this is my x-axis
x-axis and the x's and y's can take on
any value they essentially have to fill
the unit circle so if you if you were to
kind of project this top surface down
onto the x y plane you would get this
orange surface that bottom surface which
looked like this
it was essentially it was essentially
the unit circle
just like that let me draw it a little
bit neater than that i can do a better
job
so let me
all right so let me draw the unit circle
as neatly as i can
so there's my unit circle and so we
could have one parameter we can have one
parameter that essentially says how far
around the unit circle we're going so we
essentially that would be our angle and
let's use theta because that's well just
for fun we haven't used theta as a
parameter yet that's theta but if we had
x's and y's as just a function of theta
and we had a fixed radius that would
essentially just give us the points on
the outside of the unit circle but we
need to be able to have all of the x y's
that are outside and inside the unit
circle so we actually have to have two
parameters we need to not only vary this
angle but we also need to vary the
radius so we would want to trace out the
outside of that unit circle and maybe
we'd want to shorten it a little bit and
then trace it out again and then shorten
it some more and then trace it out again
and so you want to actually have a
variable radius as well and so you could
have how far out you're going you could
call that you could call that r so for
example if r is fixed and you you change
your ranges of theta then you would
change
you would you would essentially get all
of those points right over there and you
would do that for all of the r's and
from r0 all the way to r1 and you would
essentially fill up the entire unit
circle and so let's do that so r is
going to go
r is going to go between zero and one r
is going to be between zero and one and
our theta our theta is going to go all
the way around so our theta is going to
go between zero
and 2 pi this is let me write this down
i wrote 0 instead of theta our theta is
going to be greater than or equal to 0
less than or equal to 2 pi and now we're
ready to parameterize it x
of r and theta is going to be equal to
so whatever r is it's going to be r
cosine theta so x is going to be r
cosine theta
y
is going to be r sine theta that's going
to be the y value r
sine theta and now z is essentially just
a function of x
z is going to be equal to 1
minus x but x is just r
r cosine theta so there you have it we
have our
parameterization of this surface right
over here the x's and y's can take all
the values of the unit circle but then
the z is up here based on a function of
well based on really on a function of x
it's 1 minus x and so that will give us
all of the possible point right over
here on the surface you pick an x and y
then the z is going to pop us
right here someplace on that surface and
we can write it we can write it as a
position vector function instead of
calling that position vector function r
since we've already used r for radius i
will call it i don't know let's call it
i'm just going to pick a random letter
here let's call it p for position vector
function and so p
our surface p
is we can write it as actually i just
call it surface three
so surface three
surface three i'm doing that same purple
color too just so we know we're talking
about this surface three as a position
vector function as a function of theta
and r maybe i'll write r n theta because
that's how i think of things r and theta
is going to be equal to r cosine
theta i
plus
our
sine of theta j
plus 1 minus r cosine theta i need to
get some real estate here 1 minus r
cosine of theta
k
1 minus r cosine of theta k and now we
are ready to start doing all of the
business of evaluating the actual
surface integral
so the first thing we need to do is take
the cross product of this the partial of
this with respect to r and the partial
of this with respect to theta and so
let's just get down to business let's
take the cross product let's take the
cross product and so we have our i unit
vector we have our j unit vector and we
have our k unit vector
and this might get a little bit involved
we'll try our best to just work through
it give myself a little bit more space
and so the partial of this with respect
to r so let's take the partial of this
with respect to r i'll do it in blue the
partial of this with respect to r the
partial of this with respect to r is
just cosine theta i
so this is just cosine
theta i said i was going to do it in
blue and that's not blue so this is
going to be cosine
cosine theta the partial of this with
respect to r is sine theta
sine theta and the partial of this what
this term right over here with respect
to r is negative cosine theta
negative cosine theta now let's take the
partial with respect to theta the
partial of this with respect to theta is
negative r sine of theta
negative r
sine of theta the partial of this with
respect to theta is r cosine theta
r
cosine theta and the partial here this
is zero and then this would be negative
r
sine theta
negative r oh no let me be careful this
is going to be you have a negative r so
the derivative of cosine theta with
respect to theta is negative sine theta
so the negatives are going to cancel out
and so you're going to have r
r
sine
r sine theta and now we can actually
evaluate this determinant to figure out
the cross product of the partial of this
with respect to r and the partial of
this with respect to theta i'm not
writing it down just to kind of save
some real estate here
and so we have
actually maybe i will write it down just
to be clear what we're doing the partial
of s3 with respect to r
crossed with the partial of s3 with
respect to theta
is equal to
now our i component is going to be sine
theta times r sine theta so that's going
to be
r
sine squared theta minus r cosine theta
times negative cosine theta so that's
plus
r cosine squared theta all of that times
i and i already a simplification might
be popping out here at you and then you
have minus the j component the j
component is going to be cosine theta
times r sine theta so it's r
cosine
theta sine
theta and then we're going to my
subtract from that see the the negative
signs cancel out so you're going to
subtract
r sine theta cosine theta or r cosine
theta
sine theta well this is interesting
because these these are the negatives of
each other r cosine theta sine theta
minus r cosine theta sine theta this
just evaluates to zero so we have no j
component and then finally for our k
component we have cosine theta times r
cosine theta so we have r
cosine squared theta
minus r sine theta times sine theta so
or minus negative r sine theta times
sine theta so this would give you a
negative but we're going to have to
subtract it so it gives you a positive
so plus
r
sine
squared theta
k
and so this simplifies quite nicely
because this is going to be equal to
this term up here you can factor out an
r
this is r times sine squared theta plus
cosine squared theta which is just that
part simplifies to 1. so that's just r
times i so this is equal to r
times i and we do the same thing over
here this also simplifies this is
actually the same thing this also
simplifies to r so this whole thing this
whole thing simplifies let me write it
this way this is also r sine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta also
simplifies to r so you have r times k
and so if you want the magnitude of this
business so let me make it clear so the
magnitude
i'll do go back to the magenta the
magnitude of
i don't feel like rewriting it all just
copy and paste it edit copy and paste
the magnitude of all of this business
is going to be equal to
the square root
of this squared which is r squared plus
this squared which is r squared which
simplifies to this is 2r squared so you
take the square root of both of those
you get the square root the square root
of
2 times r so this is equal to the square
root of 2
times
you could it would be the absolute value
of r but we know that r only takes on
positive values r only takes some
positive values so it's the square root
of 2
square root of 2 times r which is very
nice because now we can evaluate d s d s
is going to be this business times d r
d theta so let's do it
so our surface integral the thing that
we were dealing with from the beginning
that thing right over there
so our surface integral
the surface s3
of z
ds has now is now equal to so i'm going
to use different colors for the
different variables of integration so
one on the outside and then i'll do one
on the inside i'll do the inside one in
pink
z is equal to one minus r cosine theta
so z is equal to one minus r cosine
theta it involves both so i'll use a
different color minus r cosine theta and
now i just have to integrate relative to
both of the variables 1 minus r cosine
theta oh no i have to do the times d s d
s is this thing it's this thing times d
theta d
d
r so let's see let's write this down
times square root of 2 r so let's write
that down so this times the square root
of 2r
times the square root of 2 and we can
write the square root of 2 out front
since it's a constant so let me just do
that simplify saying square root of 2
times r and now d theta d r or we could
write dr d theta either way so let's do
that d let's do d r d theta so d r
d theta we could do it either way it's
going to be about the same level of
complexity and so first we're going to
integrate with respect to r and let me
do the colors the same way actually so d
r
d r
d theta
d
theta if i've got colors i might as well
use them and actually i just realized
that i'm way out of time so actually let
me continue this in the next video we'll
set up the boundaries of integration and
then just evaluate it